I am obsessed with forming healthy
communities and that's why I started
twitch to help people watch other people
play video games on the Internet
thank you for coming to my TED talk so
in in seriousness video games and
communities truly are quite related from
our early human history we made our
entertainment together in small tribes
we shared stories around the campfire we
sang together we danced together our
earliest entertainment was both shared
and interactive
it wasn't until pretty recently on the
grand scale of human history that
interactivity took a backseat and
broadcast entertainment took over radio
and records brought music into our
vehicles into our homes TV and VHS
brought sports and drama into our living
rooms this access to broadcast
entertainment was unprecedented it gave
people amazing content around the globe
it created a shared culture for millions
of people and now if you want to go
watch or listen to Mozart you don't have
to buy an incredibly expensive ticket
and find an orchestra and if you like to
sing I can show you the world then you
have something in common
with people around the world but with
this amazing access we allowed for a
separation between creator and consumer
and the relationship between the two
became much more one-way we wound up in
a world where we had a smaller class of
professional creators and most of us
became spectators and as a result it
became far easier for us to enjoy that
content alone there's a trend
counteracting this scarcity so Vienna in
the 1900s was famous for its
hey culture and one of the big drivers
of that cafe culture was expensive
newspapers that were hard to get and as
a result people would go to the cafe and
read the shared copy there and once
they're in the cafe they meet the other
people also reading the same newspaper
they converse they exchange ideas and
they form a community in a similar way
TV and cable used to be more expensive
and so you might not watch the game at
home instead you'd go to the local bar
and cheer along with your fellow sports
fans there but as the price of media
continues to fall over time thanks to
technology this shared necessity that
used to bring our communities together
falls away we have so many amazing
options for our entertainment and yet
it's easier than ever for us to wind up
consuming those options alone our
communities are bearing the consequences
for example the number of people who
report having at least two close friends
is at an all-time low I believe that one
of the major contributing causes to this
is that our entertainment today allows
us to be separate there is one trend
reversing this atomization of our
society
modern multiplayer video games games are
like a shared campfire
they're both interactive and connecting
now these campfires may have beautiful
animations heroic quests occasionally
too many loot boxes but games today are
very different than the solitary
activity of 20 years ago they're deeply
complex they're more intellectually
stimulating and most of all they're
intrinsically social one of the recent
breakouts on resembling this change is
the Battle Royale a hundred people
parachute onto an island in a Last Man
Standing competition
think of it as being kind of like
American Idol but with a lot more
fighting and a lot less Simon Cowell you
may have heard of fortnight which is a
break out example of the Battle Royale
genre which has been played by more than
250 million people around the world it's
everyone from kids in your neighborhood
to Drake and Ellen DeGeneres 2.3 billion
people in the world play video games
early games like Tetris and Mario may
have been simple puzzles or quests but
with the rise of arcades and then
internet play and now massively
multiplayer games with huge thriving
online communities games have emerged as
the one form of entertainment where
consumption truly requires human
connection so this brings us to
streaming why do people stream
themselves playing video games and why
do hundreds of millions of people around
the world congregate to watch them I
want you all to imagine for a second
imagine you land on an alien planet and
on this planet there's a giant green
rectangle and in this green rectangle
aliens and matching outfits are trying
to push a chequered sphere between two
posts using only their feet it's pretty
evenly matched so if the ball is just
kind of going back and forth but there's
hundreds of millions of people watching
from home anyway and cheering and
getting excited and engaged right along
with them now I grew up watching sports
with my dad so I get my soccer is
entertaining and engaging but if you
don't watch sports maybe you like
watching Dancing with the Stars or you
you enjoy Top Chef regardless the
principle is the same if there's an
activity that you really enjoy
you're probably gonna like watching
other people do it with skill and
panache it might be perplexing to an
alien but bonding over a shared passion
is a human Universal so gamers grew up
expecting this live interactive
entertainment and passive consumption
just doesn't feel as fulfilling
that's why live streaming has take
with video games because live-streaming
and offers that same kind of interactive
feeling so when you imagine what's
happening on Twitch I don't want you to
think of a million live streams of video
games instead what I want you to picture
is millions of campfires some of them
are bonfires huge roaring bonfires with
hundreds of thousands of people around
them some of them are smaller more
intimate community gatherings where
everyone knows your name
let's try staking a seat by one of those
campfires right now hey Co how's it
going hey how's it going am it awesome
so I'm here at Ted with about a thousand
of my closest friends and we we thought
we'd come and join you guys for a little
stream awesome well it's great to hear
from you guys so so coach can you can
you share with the Ted audience here
what have you learned about your
community on Twitch ah
man where to begin uh you know I've been
doing this for over five years now and
if there's one thing that doesn't cease
to impress me on the daily it's just
kind of how incredible this whole thing
is for communication you know I've been
playing games for twenty years of my
life I've led online MMO guilds for over
ten and it's the kind of thing where
there's very few places in life where
you can go to meet so many people with
similar interests
I was listening a little bit earlier I
loved the campfire analogy I used a
similar one I see it all as a bunch of
people on a big couch but only one
person has a controller so you know it's
kind of like a path the snack situation
you know seven hundred people that way
but it's great and really it's just
crazy
we took Oh what is going on in chat
right now like can you fill in that
little mr. Oz because uh my eyesight
actually isn't that good but I see a lot
of emotes so this is my community this
is the coalition I stream every single
day I she just wrapped up a 2008
challenge and as such we have developed
quite a pretty incredible community here
in the channel right now we have about
6,200 people with this
what you're seeing is a spam of hello
Ted good vibe emotes love emotes this is
awesome hi guys hi everyone basically
just a huge collection of people a huge
collection of gamers that are all just
experiencing a positive event together
so is there anything that we can we pull
chat I want to ask chat a question uh is
there anything that chat would like the
world and particularly these people here
with me at Ted right now to know about
what they get out of playing video games
and being part of this community oh wow
I am already starting to see a lot of
answers here I like the good vibes best
best communities are on Twitch they get
us through the rough patches in life oh
that's that's the message I definitely
see a lot on Twitch which is very good a
very positive community very lot of
positivity a lot of positivity which is
pretty great
so it was pretty great Co is there
before right before I get back to my TED
talk which I actually should probably
get back to doing at some point can you
do you have anything else that you you
want to share with me or any question
you wanted to ask you've always wanted
to get out there before before an
audience honestly not too much I mean I
I absolutely love what you're doing
right now you know I think that the
interactive streaming is is probably the
big unexplored frontier of the future
and entertainment and just thank you for
doing everything you're doing up there
the more people to hear about you and
what you do the better for everyone on
here awesome cow thank you
thanks so much and I'm gonna get back to
giving this talk now but we should catch
up later
sounds great
um so that was a new way to interact we
could influence what happened on the
stream we could co-create the experience
along with him and we really had a
multiplayer experience with chat and
with Co at which we've started calling
this as a result multiplayer
entertainment because going from
watching a video alone to watching a
live interactive stream is similar to
the difference between going from
playing a single-player game to playing
a multiplayer game gamers are often at
the forefront of exploration and new
technology micro computers for example
were used early on for video games and
the very first handheld digital
mass-market devices weren't cellphones
they were game boys for video games and
as a result one way that you can get a
hint of what the future might hold is to
look to this fun interactive sandbox of
video games and ask yourself what what
are these gamers doing today and that
might give you a hint as to what the
future is going to hold for all of us
one of the things we're already seeing
on Twitch is multiplayer entertainment
coming to sports so twitch in the NFL
teamed up to offer live-streaming
football but instead of Network
announcers in suits streaming the game
we got twitch users to come in and
stream it themselves on their own
channel and interact with their
community and make it a real multiplayer
experience and so I actually think that
if you look out to the future only
hundreds of people today get to be
sports announcers it's a tiny tiny
number of people who have that
opportunity but sports are about to go
see player and that means that anyone
who wants to around the world is gonna
get the opportunity to become a sports
announcer to give it a shot
and I think that's gonna unlock
incredible amounts of new talent for all
of us and we're not gonna be asking did
you catch the game instead we're gonna
be asking whose channel did you catch
the game on we already see this
happening with cooking with singing we
even see people streaming welding and
all of this stuff is gonna happen around
the metaphorical campfire there's gonna
be millions of these campfires lit over
the next few years and on every topic
you're gonna be able to find a campfire
that'll allow you to bond with your
people around the world for most of
human history Entertainment was simply
multiplayer we sang together in person
we shared news together in the town
square in person and somewhere along the
way that two-way conversation turned
into a one-way transmission as someone
who cares about communities I am excited
for a world where our entertainment
could connect us instead of isolating us
a world where we can bond with each
other over our shared interests and
create real strong communities games
streams and the interactions they
encourage are only just beginning to
turn the wheel back to our interactive
community rich multiplayer past thank
you all for sharing this experience here
with me and may you all find your best
campfire
[Applause]